станете луганська у нас трьох пілотних зон
якудза рамка вaм рішенням мінську
контактну групу малий демілітаризувати
srt вуха але вивезення що pedross справа
українських bronn excel за місця на може
вже два ти ж не просто виступає містер
біміш conti називаю що в зоні
розведення зал і шити та соціального
житлові об'єкти
мета приклад на думку експертом на
монстра та валуни не часток перекладного
рішення на встановлена ​​адже побачилися
турин саме євро хований про важливі нюанси
привіт форумі коли роз'їдають сили
завищувати про ітан я ще буду в середині
хто тут нам цьому контролю цик сірих
зонах че там за влада буду отже там люди
живуть і люди нами виступають проти тіла
і бояться що за містер мер я
розпускається односторонньо заходами цик
сірих зон про ці сірі зони
палицею доусон розведення вона може по
стежка ти навіки постріляти і вигляду б е
він і продовжу it's коржі тис на
обстріл це порушення приклад я з 2 ст
Урин на думку експертів причина невдач
це сама що й раніше на політ панщину
посередники ти їх то світ би гарант плати
оскільки місяцем наш кінцям поліцейська
місія про ікони одноразового рило
української політики та своїм завданням
novritsch відсічі ці
поліцейськими поліцейська місія на донбасі
могла б бути рішенням нібито чи вигляді
слав і туди чек не травня 2014 року
про нинішню ситуацію ціни мою думку мало
що змінило б регіоні заміни ти
ситуацію могла гинути в будинку, а праворуч
їх весь ваш к.о. артилерією та танками
столітті гарантувала до 3 травня перемир'я
дихає уді можна було б каже і провід
він несе року тобі сказали про б 2
експерт поважає чого самостійно ворогові
лева ти конфлікт україна не зможе
джеф туман і затікав і на русі я сара
повинні вийшли ахім у площину і не
міжнародної коаліції на піт ринку
україни продумую для чого на думку
експертів нової б стати і виставки
прокуратури нідерланди в диво usb цього
на донбасі малайзійського боїнгу